all smiles they would have known the
world was watching
but this felt like a genuine reunion
two sons who have had their troubles
coming together with princess diana's
brother
and sisters to remember their mother
sharing a joke and the duty of unveiling
the statue
a lasting tribute how diana used her
spotlight
to shine a light on others
paul that the princess was a very public
figure and in many respects an icon
that she was somebody's mother so that's
i paid the greatest heed to both princes
and what they had to say
in 2017 when they commissioned the
statue they could not have seemed closer
and nobody expected the very public rift
that would follow
at prince philip's funeral they at least
were seen talking
today many will hope another step
forward
i think it'll take quite a lot of work
for the for the relationship to be
restored to what it was but i think that
you know baby steps and
the fact that they were together the
fact that they were smiling
together laughing even at times
clearly talking is a real step forward
yes it is difficult to know if this was
a show of unity
just for one day but it did feel like
engagements from
a couple years ago when they were on
much better terms
again bouncing off each other today in a
way that only brothers can
in a joint statement william harry said
that every day they wish their mother
was still with us
their love for her has never been in any
doubt
now forever etched in the gardens where
they enjoyed
so much time together rhiannon mills
sky news at kensington palace